[Music]
possible douche is a combination of
whacking and voting we are a dance
troupe but we're more than that we are a
family we vote we whack we dance around
the city and we fight for love and
equality this great big story is brought
to you by Delta when we venture out into
the world we see all that we share my
name is Jojo Selena I'm a dancer
choreographer a dance teacher and I'm
also the overall father of house
ladouche house ledouche are a dance
troupe but we're more than that we're a
family we performed everywhere around
the city we represent the LGBTQ
community but we're trying to bridge
everyone together whacking and voguing
is an expression that came from the
oppressed communities and the struggle
that we went through looking for self
love and acceptance
I started housing a dish back in 2006 he
helped me transition from being a
straight man into a queer man being not
able to express my feminine side creates
a lot of confusion and self-hate every
time I perform I feel the release of
that frustration and confusion
I feel really free but it's not just for
LGBTQ - plus community it's also for
everyone to grasp on if they feel like
that style speaks to them
[Music]
hustle a douche is an alternative family
it doesn't matter where you come from
like for example I'm a cisgender
heterosexual woman and I'm here to
support LGBTQ 2 plus community I'm
originally from Japan I emigrated to
Canada by myself and I grew up in a very
conservative culture but inside I was
always rebel I think LGBTQ community
really helped me to be Who I am just
being a woman awakened all of us each
one of us have stories about wanting to
be accepted
I brought voguing and whacking into
Vancouver because it's a language that
we can learn to communicate and express
whatever we feel you can be anything you
want and be whatever you want you can be
masculine you can be as feminine as you
want and you just feel good in fabulous
[Music]
so how's the ledouche is like a shower
so shower the whole entire world with
colors and paint it the way you want to
paint it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]